[Music]
with every change comes loss
i struggle to motivate myself sometimes
that maybe i have to go
because what i don't know what else
there is how the did i end up in
this situation
depression i can't concentrate at work
and grief
screaming at the top of my lungs and
sadness screw you i don't want any help
i'm going to kill myself
after eight plus years and over 600
conversations
i've compiled a fairly massive library
of practical information and timeless
wisdom
that due to the nature of the internet
often gets lost
in the seemingly endless feed of new
content released every single day
and so i felt compelled to experiment
with
a new episode format one that features a
compilation
of some of the best guests i've had on
the show in the past
and centers around a single theme or
subject matter
this is the second deep dive the second
master class episode we've done
part one about the microbiome was
released back in january
and if you missed it you can find a link
to that episode in the description below
but today we're continuing the
experiment with an extremely important
subject mental health
all of the guests featured in this
episode are either
experts in one of the various mental
health fields
or are individuals who have gleaned
wisdom about mental health
through struggle these are truly some of
the best
most inspiring conversations i've had on
this topic
and you can find the full episodes for
each in the description below
for too long talking about mental health
has been a social taboo
many people have historically been too
ashamed to
admit they need help and to seek it out
and our society's lack of mental health
awareness and education
has led to an epidemic of chronic stress
and severe loneliness as well as a rise
in things like suicide
anxiety depression and alzheimer's
disease and other forms of dementia
and it is thus vital that we talk about
it
so to better understand mental health we
begin today's show by talking about
therapy with laurie gottlieb lori is a
los angeles-based psychotherapist
she's a journalist she's an author of
the book maybe you should talk to
someone
and our conversation was about what
happens when
a therapist experiences her own personal
crisis and seeks help but it's also a
broader conversation about
mental well-being in general which makes
it the perfect place
to start
do you think everybody should be in
therapy people
since the book came out everybody asked
me that and and
they do and and i think it's interesting
i'm not
you know i think everybody can benefit
from therapy i don't think everybody
needs to be in therapy but i do think
this i think that so many times people
come to therapy
later than they should um meaning that
you know
we we think about our physical
well-being different from our emotional
well-being so if somebody
feels like something is wrong with their
body like you're having chest pain
you'll probably go to the cardiologist
before you have a massive heart attack
but if somebody feels like oh something
doesn't feel right emotionally
we tend to ignore it or minimize it um
you know will i have a roof over my head
and food on the table
so i don't really need help and what
happens is they think that they can just
make the feelings go away or not pay
attention to them
but when you don't pay attention to
feelings they become stronger
and they come out you know in a behavior
in an irritability or in a
short-temperedness or in a
you know self-defeating self-sabotaging
way of being in the world whatever it is
or an
inability to sleep whatever um and so
people then don't come to therapy
until they're having some kind of crisis
um and it's like they're having an
emotional heart attack i mean there's no
downside
well time money um
the the big the biggest downside i think
for people even though there are
logistical problems that are very real
um is that a lot of people kind of
unconsciously know that if they go to
therapy they
might need to make changes right yeah
you know it's like if i go to therapy
like i might need to do something
different in my life i might need to be
uncomfortable
and i don't want to be uncomfortable so
i'd rather just you know
just keep things the way they are right
status quo in the book i say
insight is the booby prize of therapy
because you can have all the insight in
the world
like oh now i understand why i keep
picking those guys but if you don't make
changes out in the world
i.e pick other guys um the insight is
useless so many times people in couples
therapy will say like oh now i
understand why
you know i get really triggered by that
that when you do that
you know or and why i react that way but
then they don't change anything yeah
well you're wasting your time if you're
not going to change anything so i think
in therapy you have to be both
vulnerable and accountable so you have
to be vulnerable but you also have to be
accountable for
what are you going to do with the work
that we're doing how are you going to
make some tangible changes in your
behavior
when you leave here the change part is
so hard right and people don't realize
that they think oh it's
positive change so it should be easy
because people want
something better to happen but with
every change
comes loss yeah the revelation feels
like progress but it's actually not
doing anything i mean i've been sober a
long time and you know the adage in 12
step is self enough self knowledge will
avail you nothing
right and when people say to me like
well why do you think you're an
alcoholic like what happened when you're
it's
and i've learned like it's interesting
to explore that but i could spend all of
my time trying to
deconstruct that and it actually doesn't
help
you know it doesn't it doesn't inform
how i'm going to make decisions going
forward
i have this toolbox now and i apply
these tools to how i make decisions and
how i run things by other people
that have allowed me to maintain my
sobriety and
and you know become a more productive
member of society
so for me it's about like the actionable
tools and
i think it is like it's so difficult for
people
to change and in my experience in my own
personal experience like i didn't change
until i was in
you know the the pain of the pain of
continuing on the path that i was on
exceeded the fear of
you know the unknown should i change
right so
you know what is that like like how do
you get people
short of having to have some you know
cataclysm in their life to
make those adjustments and actually you
know put your information and your
insight
into forward motion there was something
that my therapist said to me that i
write about in the book where he said
you know where i was like just feeling
trapped by all of these sort of external
circumstances and i wasn't willing to
make changes i wasn't willing to look at
what i could do differently
and he said you remind me of this
cartoon and it's of this prisoner
shaking the bars
desperately trying to get out but on the
right and the left the bars are open
and it was like you know at first i
thought that's really cheesy but
but then i thought wait a minute he's
right because so many of us would rather
be the prisoner shaking the bar
saying i can't do anything about this we
don't want to look that it's open on the
right or the left because then if we
walk out
and we go into the sunlight and there
are no bars and we're free
with freedom comes responsibility and
now we have to take responsibility for
our lives we can't say oh the problem is
you know that i'm trapped here right now
now it's like anything that happens is
i'm responsible for that
and so change is hard for that reason
you know it's it's easier to feel
trapped in the
whatever childhood drama you know that
you're you're reenacting
than to actually do something different
where
you might have to be responsible for
your choices
[Music]
taking responsibility for your mental
health is absolutely key
and it can be a hard pill to swallow for
the first time but
ultimately it's really the only way
forward if you want to make positive
change in your life
but what do we do when we just can't
find
the strength within ourselves to work
past our fear take responsibility for
our failures
and seek that help i mean mental health
disorders can
literally impede our decision-making
processes just by nature of what they
are
because they deal with the mind and how
do you solve a problem of the mind when
that same mind created the problem in
the first place
well this next clip a section from my
conversation with author and journalist
johan hari
addresses that very question johan is
written for the new york times
the los angeles times and many other
outlets he is also the author of two
quite profound books
chasing the scream and his more recent
book lost connections which
is a quite compelling deep dive into the
nature of depression
and its underlying causes my original
conversation with johann was
a super interesting exploration into
those causes into those
reasons and the cultural drivers behind
both
addiction and depression as well as
mental health in general
what contributes to their malignancy
what compels so many
in this unhealthy direction and why they
are so difficult to overcome
i'm very excited to share this clip with
you because it moves the way we think
about our mental health journey
away from being self-focused and instead
places it within the context of
community
as johann shares the stories of a woman
in pain
a boy with adhd a man in custody
and the neighbors who save their lives
[Music]
in the summer of 2011 on a big anonymous
housing project in berlin
uh a woman called nuriachengis climbed
out of her wheelchair and she put a sign
in her window she lived on the ground
lived in a ground floor apartment
and the sign said something like i got a
notice saying i'm going to be evicted
from my apartment next friday
so next thursday night i'm going to kill
myself
no one knew this woman people start to
knock on a door and they're like
do you need any help i should screw you
i don't want any help i'm going to kill
myself
and outside the apartment some of the
people who lived there didn't know each
other started chatting
and one of them had this idea there's a
big thoroughfare that goes into the
center of berlin that runs through this
project it's called coty
but i have idea if we just block the
street
for a day on a saturday
there'll probably be a fuss the media
will probably come they'll probably let
nuria stay in her apartment
maybe there'll be some pressure for us
to you know um
our rents to be kept down too and this
disaster to stop
um so decided to do it they went and
built a barricade in the middle of the
road
uh and nuria was like well i'm going to
kill myself anyway i might as well let
them reel me out
matter they wheeler out there and the
media did come and they interviewed
nuria and the other residents
it's a bit of a fuss and it gets to the
end of the day and the police say
okay you've had your fun take it down
but the people who lived in cotty said
well hang on a minute
you haven't told noah she gets to stay
and actually
we want to rent freeze for our entire
block this whole housing project
so when you give us that we'll take it
down because they knew the minute they
left the barricade the police would just
tear it down
so people start to sign up to man the
barricade right
don't know each other um tanya in her
tiny little mini skirt was paired with
nuria in her full
hijab right and uh these kind of
pairings were happening all over coty
and first i think they had i think they
had the thursday night shift
tanya and nuria are like we've got
nothing to talk about right what are we
going to talk about it couldn't be more
likely
um so they sit there through the night
barely speaking first few times
as the nights went on um they started to
talk they realized something incredibly
powerful in common
and nuria told tanya something she'd
never told anyone
so she had come to berlin when she was
16 from a village in turkey
with her two young children and she was
sent to raise enough money
to send back her husband to come and
join her after she'd been in berlin for
a year she got word from home that her
husband had died
and she told tanya that she'd always
told people that he died of
a heart attack actually he died of
tuberculosis
which was seen as like a disease of
poverty they realized they had both been
kind of children with children
themselves in this place that they were
very that where they've been very
frightened they realized they're saying
really powerful and common these kind of
pairings were happening all over cotty
there was a young lad called mehmet
who kept being they kept nearly throwing
him out of school they said he had adhd
he was paired with this grumpy old white
guy he said he didn't believe in direct
action because he loved stalin but in
this case he'd make an exception
they did a shift together he the old
white guy started helping mehmet with
his homework then it started doing a lot
better
as one of the muslim women there said to
me we all realized we had to take these
small steps to understand each other
after the process to be going on for
about a year one day um
a man arrived at cotty he was in his
early 50s was called he's called tonkai
and it's um clear when you meet tonka
he's got some kind of cognitive
difficulties he's been living homeless
but he also has an amazing energy about
him everyone immediately liked him
and after he was there for two or three
days that by this time they'd actually
turned their barricade into a permanent
structure in the street
and they saw the roof and everything and
they said you know you should start
living here we don't want you to be
homeless he started living there
he became a much loved part of the cotty
protest
nine months later one day the police
came to inspect they become inspect
every now and then
and tonkai doesn't like it when people
argue he thought the police were arguing
so he went to try to hug one of the
officers they thought he was attacking
them so they
they they arrested him that was when it
was discovered
that tunkai had been shut away in a
psychiatric hall a psychiatric hospital
often in a padded cell for 20 years he'd
escaped one day lived on the streets for
a few months and they found his way to
coty
so the police took him back to the
psychiatric hospital and he's put back
in his cell
at which point the entire cotty housing
project
turned into a kind of free tonkai
movement right they descend
on this psychiatric hospital but i
remember uli
um carlton born one of the protesters
saying to them you know
you don't love him he doesn't belong
with you
we love him he belongs with us i
remember thinking you know
how many of us if someone carted us away
would have hundreds of people
descending saying no we love this person
the bosnian writer alexander heyman said
home is where people notice when you're
not there
right lots of people are homeless in
that sense
um and i remember thinking so clearly in
coty think about how distressed these
people were
nuria was about to kill herself mehmed
kept being nearly thrown out of school
they said
he had adhd tonkai was shut away in a
padded cell
loads of them were depressed and anxious
these people did not need to be drugged
most of them they needed to be together
they needed to have a sense of meaning
and purpose they needed a home
[Music]
i love that once again you can find the
links to these full conversations
in the description below next up in this
mental health deep dive is
alexi pappas i adore this woman she is
truly extraordinary
not only is alexi an olympic athlete
she's also a poet
a writer a filmmaker and an author her
book
is called bravey and it's a beautiful
lovely read i highly suggest everybody
check it out
i think most of us consider mental
health to be
chiefly an emotional or chemical issue
we know mental disorders have to do with
something in our brains
but we tend to think of them as thoughts
or feelings gone awry
as opposed to something physically
broken a malady
more akin to a scratch or a sprained
ankle
but in this next clip alexi shares her
experience of focusing on the physical
side of mental health
and the way that subtle shift in
perspective changed her life and put her
on the path toward healing
so i was in total denial that i was sick
because i i didn't understand that
your brain can get injured just like
your knee i just i didn't understand
that
and so i was of the mindset as i had
always been in my life that i needed to
keep pressing forward and
and fix all on my own whatever it was
that i was feeling
to the point where i wasn't sleeping but
i
tried to force myself to sleep and you
know that's
it's called falling asleep for a reason
you have to let it
right let it happen and you're being a
good type a athlete you're trying to
will everything
into existence and then i started to
have these even darker thoughts and
that's when i felt like
i understood my mom in a way that i
never wanted to understand her
like i it's you have these thoughts that
like you want to
die and i don't think you really want to
want to die
but the thoughts say otherwise and
that's when
you're sick um and it was terrifying
because i always i've always been afraid
my whole life
for the moment that um that that might
happen to me
and and and then when it did but before
i understood
that there was a way to get better i
thought that that was just my
fate that like that was it now happened
to me
and because the narrative i was told
about her was
she just had to go like she just she was
so sick that
she had to go and i was like well i
guess i'm so sick
that maybe i have to go because what i
don't know what else there is
wow
that's so embarrassing honestly to share
because i don't feel that way anymore
but i didn't understand and i think it's
sad that
even someone who was susceptible to
these things you know my family history
was
public right there was no prehab
if you will if you want to call like if
we want to use this body comparison if
the brain
is a body part i had no prehab i had no
preparation to deal with this
and it wasn't until my my dad because of
his experience with my mom made me get
help
that i met a doctor dr arpaio who told
me
very simply that i was sick and that my
brain had a scratch on it
and that it could get injured like any
other body part but it could also heal
like any other body part and suddenly
everything like
it literally turned around in a day not
i wasn't happy
but i believed that i could be on a path
to healing
um and that i could commit to it just
like i would an olympic dream
we are in a place where we can accept i
think as a
as a world that elite athletes and high
achievers can have these
mental injuries these mental illnesses
but i think
the most important thing now is like
what do we do about them and that was
something that i found um
i find that sometimes you know we point
fingers at the like
the pinnacle institutions that we're
chasing but actually i
truly think that this kind of education
or shift has to happen much younger
and on a more universal level
not just at those pinnacles so what
would that look like if you were in
charge and could put those things in
place
well let's look at body
um the way we've approached the body and
like how that's progressed over the last
let's say 10 years like 10 years ago i
don't think my dad
or my friend's little sister would have
seen a
pt for their body uh without
having an injury meaning like regularly
take care of their body
and so just looking at that world we've
come a long way to accepting that our
body is something not only
elite athletes should take care of but
everybody should take care of
and that we should take care of it
before it's a problem ideally if you are
able to have that kind of
support and it's not um
there's just like systems and you can
always you can get that kind of help if
you can and
need it right and i think with mental
health
the the comparing it to
healing and injury is so simple to me
and makes
so much sense so what it would look like
to me is
accepting honestly that our brain is a
body part and it can get injured
and when it gets injured just like when
we
break our leg or feel something strange
in our leg
we have no shame about sharing that
something is off
and we get help and we know where to get
help and
it's either built into the system that
we're in like a team might have a physio
they might have a psychologist too
or someone can refer you to their
favorite physio or their favorite psycho
like there's just more
accessibility just like there is in like
the pt world
and then we get that help and we are as
kind to ourselves as we are hard on
ourselves
knowing that it's not going to resolve
overnight like nobody is demanding that
somebody's broken leg healed tomorrow
and so why are we demanding that
somebody's depression heal tomorrow
because it's uncomfortable for us to
talk about right we want to pretend that
it doesn't exist or
their shame or right because it's
invisible but if we like think about it
more like an injury
like no one can see your torn hamstring
either
but they know that it's there if you say
it and they they believe it's there
so if we just see it as more of a
physical injury which it is
then i think it becomes a little less uh
subjective and a little more objective
and in the meantime just being told like
you're going to feel this way
allows you to be in acceptance rather
than
beating yourself up because you woke up
again and didn't feel good
you're less you don't have the secondary
emotion of being offended by the sadness
as much you almost
are like you wake up with the sadness
like it's
you know i don't have a child but i
think about like if a baby's crying and
you're at the grocery store
the baby's crying but you still gotta
get the milk you know so i think about
it in that way
sometimes where you almost have a sense
of humor about it
or at least some levity to understand
that it's there it will be there for a
while and you're in the process of
making it go away
actions change first then thoughts
then feelings and in that order and that
was another
life-saving rule basically because
what i've observed from my mom was that
her caretakers were trying to force the
feelings and she was trying to force the
feelings
to change and we can't they
they follow our thoughts which follow
our actions right
actions then thoughts then
feelings practical advice from somebody
who has learned that lesson firsthand
but what kinds of actions should we take
therapy physical therapy reaching out to
our neighbors
and how do we know if those actions are
the right ones
well those questions lead directly to
the heart of this next conversation
with dr rangan chatterjee for those
unfamiliar
dr chatterjee is a pioneer in the field
of progressive functional medicine
widely regarded as one of the most
influential doctors
in the uk rangan is double board
certified
in internal medicine and family medicine
and holds a non-arts degree
in immunology he also hosts the popular
feel better live more podcast which i've
appeared on twice
and has been widely featured on an array
of prominent media outlets like the new
york times
the bbc forbes the guardian financial
times and many others
in his practice dr chatterjee has found
himself increasingly treating patients
on the daily who
suffer the downstream implications of
living with chronic stress
and other mental health disorders this
in turn
has given him the opportunity to treat
his patients in
unconventional ways including a
surprising approach
you'll hear more about right now
one of the prescriptions i give people
and i don't particularly like the term
prescription but
one of the recommendations i make is to
have a daily dose of pleasure even
just for five minutes now
again just to bring this to life i had a
patient
52 year old chat or maybe 53 you know
early 50s chap
cfo of a local plastics company right
again comes in to see me he's worried
doctor
do i have depression what's going on
i struggle to motivate myself sometimes
i can't concentrate at work
i feel quite indifferent about my
relationships you know what is going on
so as always i try and unpack different
aspects of their lives so do you like
your job
yeah not really you know it's so so i
have to do it and i've got a family i
need to provide for them i said okay
fine how's your relationship with your
wife
you know what so so you know i don't
really see her that much it's fine
um do you um do you have any hobbies
dog i don't have time for hobbies i'm
busy i kept that late
i thought okay what about weekends
weekends i've got to do the household
chores i've got to take the kids to
their classes
i don't have time for hobbies so
the prescription i gave him the
recommendation i made some at the end of
doing this and again so that i don't get
it not that it matters if i get
criticized but just so people understand
i did do the safety nesting that has
required of me i didn't feel he was an
active suicide risk i didn't do
all these sort of various things that i
have to do as a doctor i did check
but ultimately what i felt was that he
didn't have any passion in his life
right and i said look did i know you
don't do any hobbies now did you
ever have a hobby well
yeah i guess you know when i was a kid
when i was a teenager i loved playing
with train sets
i said okay great do you have a train
set at home
i've got one at home it's in my attic
i've not seen it for years
i said okay look what i would love you
to do when you go home tonight
is to get your train set hands and
you've got a smirk on your face right
yeah i get it hey i have no judgment on
people's hobbies i had a train set when
i was a kid
well i thought you were i thought you
were smoking on the fact that the doc
he came in to see me with a with a
problem he was concerned about and my
prescription was to get out of his truck
i'm with you on that okay you're with me
on that okay so
so he again he agrees to go and do this
so he goes away i don't see him then
it is not uncommon in general practice
in the uk for you not to be able to
follow up every single patient you just
simply cannot do that
so i got on with my job i was you know
doing my thing
three months later i finished my morning
clinic and then we have something called
home visits
in the uk where you know normally after
your morning clinic you will then
have a list from reception of people who
are maybe elderly and firm who can't get
out to the practice and you go and visit
them at home to look after them
so i was i went to the car park to go do
my home business and i bumped into his
wife
and i said hey hey look um you know
how's your husband getting on
he said that's chassis i feel like i've
got the the guy i'm married back again
he comes home from work he's straight
onto his train set
he's on ebay all the time trying to buy
collector's items and he's
he and he's subscribed to this monthly
collector's magazine now
right so she's happy wearing his
conductor hat
house hey but she's happy but i still
haven't seen him right
again roughly three months later
i'm just going through my clinic as
usual and i see his name pop up and he
has had some blood tests at a
well-manned check and he's coming in to
see me to go through them
welcoming in and before we go into the
results i say hey look how are you
getting on
he says doc i feel like a different
person life is great i said my mood's
better i've got energy
i said okay cool you know how's your job
job i love it i'm really getting a lot
out of my job now
how's your relationship with your wife
really really good i feel really close
to her
so just like that case i don't know how
long we've been chatting for maybe an
hour ago
just like that uh story about the kid
who was feeling low and who had a
friendship deficiency did this guy have
a mental health problem
sure i think he had symptoms that would
be consistent i could have made
i could have labeled him and given him a
diagnosis
right or did this chap really have
a deficiency of passion in his life and
the remarkable thing for me is when that
passion deficiency gets corrected
not only does he feel better in himself
but everything else in his life
starts to come back online the job that
he couldn't stand before
now he enjoys the relationship that was
a bit tired and he felt a bit
indifferent about
now he's feeling closer to his wife what
generally happens
is that individual that came into your
office
would go into would either not seek help
or in the event that that person has the
wherewithal to seek help would go to a
practitioner
and at least in the united states the
system is set up
wherein that doctor would only have 15
minutes with that person
and it's a set up rigged to diagnose and
prescribe and that person would leave
with some kind of antidepressant
medication most likely and would then
consider themselves depressed or
clinically
you know having some kind of mental
melody without that
tactile kind of real world practical
solution that you would
implement because you had the
opportunity to provide that person with
a little bit more bandwidth
i'm so passionate about this rich
because it's not as hard
as we think it is take small small steps
find one thing you heard us talk about
today that resonates with you
that you think you want to do don't pick
something that you don't want to do
pick something you do want to do figure
out how you can introduce a very small
change in that area
consistently for the next few days and
then reassess
and i bet you more often than not
you're going to feel good about yourself
your identity is going to change because
suddenly what happens then
oh i'm the kind of person who can make
behavior change
i've done that for the last five days
that is the approach
i have seen over and over again work for
people
please if you are struggling take
something from that
put that into your practice not next
monday right
maybe put into practice tomorrow
[Music]
i absolutely love that advice put it
into practice tomorrow
start small start today even but
does taking action with your mental
health always have to be so
literal is it possible that there are
circumstances where the best action you
can take is to rest
well that's the perspective of my next
guest caroline berkel
caroline is a 2012 olympian
a 23-time all-american swimmer an ncaa
champion
and an ncaa record holder one of my very
favorite people i
absolutely adore her she speaks about
accepting our emotions
vulnerability mentorship honest
communication
and the potency latent in rest
she has an amazing and powerful
perspective and i can't wait for you
to hear it your feelings
are valid they're not right or wrong
they're not measured
but learning how to use them
constructively whether it's through
sharing or understanding it
communicating
and being able to use those and move
forward with whatever that is is the key
so i think we we get wrapped up in not
saying anything
because we're afraid to upset somebody
but if there's somebody that you can
share
how you feel with and that feels like a
safe space for you
it feels safe to validate your feelings
say it's okay you feel that way
let's get a little more information
about that what is it that's really
showing up there
and really understanding the the human's
heart
first they're gonna be able to perform
better they're gonna be able to take
that and use whatever that is
and turn it into something constructive
because i think we we get stuck
in our feelings and we get stuck just
thinking they don't matter brushing them
away
pushing them away really there's so much
power in that there's so much
information
to be had in that that's beautiful
regardless of if they're positive or
negative you can
take that re-mold it and turn it into an
amazing
performance grade on a test
relationship with somebody with your
family members um
extracurricular whatever it is that that
person's wanting to do
so that's something i like to say
because i think
we're shameful of our feelings we're
shameful of what that means
there's nothing wrong with that it's
just information
and i wish i would have known that i
wish i would have been okay knowing that
however i felt was okay
and that it wasn't there was nothing
wrong with it it was just information
yeah that's beautiful i think it's super
important i feel like
at least in the context of sport there
has been a lot of progress
and movement in the right direction in
terms of better understanding
that aspect of it i mean i'm two
generations older than you
but when i see you know the way that
young
athletes are being coached and mentored
now compared to what it was like when i
was a kid i mean
yeah that was a long time ago but you
know of course much more
there's much more to be gleaned and
learned totally mental health is at the
forefront right now
people are caring about how people feel
and
and you know this is an important thing
to note is that
you can be struggling and also
be okay with your performances you can
admit that you're having a hard time and
also you'll
you'll still be okay you can still be
and do great things
i think there's a um
a misunderstanding there that if i again
back to that
if i share that i'm depressed or having
a hard time
or uh going through something
then that means i know it's gonna it's
gonna
be well impinge on your performance
right i mean that's the whole message of
the weight of gold right it's like kind
of a call to action to embrace
that aspect of what it means to be
vulnerable and
and to have the courage to raise your
hand and ask for help absolutely
the shrouding of it the hiding of it
because you're supposed to be
you know this bulletproof individual is
not in service to anybody and certainly
not yourself
and it's not complaining it's owning
it's self-ownership
you know i think there's a difference
between complaining i have some athletes
say well i don't want to complain
it's if we can shift it to its
self-ownership
then we can take that and use it just
because
you're having a hard time have asked for
help etc doesn't mean you're all of a
sudden gonna perform poorly
right it doesn't mean that you're not
focusing on your swimming or your
baseball or whatever it means that
you're doing something for your mental
health which will then help that
so it's a perspective shift right it
does require
some level of of mind-body integration
though because you have to know
when you are copping out like am i just
am i just wimping out here
or am i really um in jeopardy where i
need
some outside help like there is a
difference and if you don't have that
kind of
intuition then you know you might be
just
you know indulging in your laziness yeah
you know
instead of really being in peril but
that's where
great coaches and mentors come in
because if somebody is vulnerable enough
to share whatever it is
then they can catch that and be able to
change that and turn that into something
otherwise they will just sit in their
so to speak and you know let it go to
and
well whatever i'm just copping out you
know so if they can
articulate that communicate that
information to whomever
you know coach mentor and this is where
coaches and mentors can can hear
that taking that information and being
able to help somebody
being able to to identify it without
shame
and turn it into something better call
them out on what it is
in a nice way in a beautiful way like
hey you're you're tough
let's make something out of this like
we're not going to let this happen to
you here
that's where things can shift for the
positive
this is applicable outside of sport in
the workplace like a boss
you know employee relationship or how
management is structured so that
the work staff feels like they can you
know raise certain issues and the
manager is creating an environment
that's conducive to that i think you
know ultimately leads to a much more
effective
healthy place to work or you know
environment to excel
as an athlete absolutely and that is one
of the most important things that i
think any organization can hold
coaches teams usa swimming is that if
the standard is held there and if people
are all believing in whatever
leadership there is and the leaders are
able to develop these people
athletes you know employees whatever it
is into a space of
vulnerability openness and action
on what it is that we're doing not just
talking about it and sitting around it's
like actually acting on it
whether that action is let's sit with
this for a minute or that action is
let's take action and do something right
now
both of those things are beautiful
that's how
things develop and um
yeah those are my greatest learnings
from mike deboers he was just very much
either like okay let's now that we have
that information
let's either go this way and act on it
immediately or
i'm gonna let you sit with that for a
second i'm here right here next to you
but i'm gonna let you sit with that for
a second and like knowing that i was
like held in that space
i think you know reflecting back that
makes all the difference because either
way is an action
mm-hmm you're giving you're empowering
them either way right i gotta figure it
out on their own either way
but it's the person that's gonna hold
steady and sturdy there that's holding
the leadership standard
yeah this next segment is from
one of the most influential people in my
life perhaps more than
any other single person beyond my wife
and my kids
he has had without knowing it and
unbelievably profound
impact on my journey on my career
and how i think about and pursue
self-expression
his name is stephen pressfield he's a
novelist
he's a screenwriter and the guy behind
some of the most important
non-fiction books on creativity that
i've ever read including of course
the war of art which you've likely heard
me talk about quite frequently
on the podcast because it impacted me so
deeply
but chief among his many messages on
creativity is a concept he calls
resistance negative self-talk
is such a prevalent part of our mental
lives
and can often lead to shame spirals of
anxiety
depression self-sabotage and ultimately
self-harm or suicidal ideation and
stephen
shares his experience of how to suit up
and win
this war against the negative force of
resistance
i hold this man and his work in the
absolute highest regard
i can't thank him enough for the gift of
his contributions
his books literally changed my life and
i can't wait to share his wisdom
with all of you right now
resistance is this negative force of
self-sabotage that uh
will work against us anytime we try to
move from a lower level
to a higher level ethically morally
creatively
if you have an idea for a book if you
have an idea for a podcast
if you have an idea for this studio or
something that you want to do
and i want to ask you about this rich a
voice will come into your head right
immediately
that will say who are you to do put this
thing together
this has been done a million times and
it's been done better than you
ever could do or ever would do you're
too old you're too young you're too fat
you're too skinny you don't have enough
education
you have too much education etc etc
and that negative force is universal
i can tell you from the thousands of
emails i've got
and not only is it universal but
it's the same voice in every in all of
our heads
you know it may be tailored a little bit
to you or to me but it's
it's the same voice and i was never
aware of that
and once i could sort of give a name to
it
then then i could say okay now i have
something i can deal with
how can i overcome this can i develop
habits
that will help me overcome it can i
organize my day
in such a way can i change my mindset in
such a way
and so anyway that's kind of my
definition of resistance well the first
step seems to be
uh disassociating your identity
from the resistance itself because i
think
what we all kind of do is is is
self-identify with that that is part of
a great way to put it right i've never
heard that before that's exactly it
well you have talked about you know this
idea that exists
outside of yourself right if you're just
thinking well i can't do it
this is me telling myself this as
opposed to this external force
that we can you know define as this
pernicious
entity working at odds with our this
our our effort to climb to that you know
elevated place
what you just said rich is exactly right
the of disassociating
this concept of resistance is fact of
resistance
from your own identity like when we hear
this voice in our head
that says you're not good enough it's
all been done etc etc
what makes that so powerful against us
is we think it's our own thoughts
we think oh that's me assessing the
situation objectively
but it's not it's this other siren
voice this this force that's just out
there that's a fact of nature
and once we can say oh that's not me
that kind of is the key to the whole
thing and then again
there is this force of resistance that
when we try to ask that question of
ourselves
you know who am i what do i love what am
i what is my gift
this force of resistance will try to
stop us from examining it it'll try to
distract us it'll try to
push us off into shadow careers or
shadow activities or something that's
not in that in that
in that way that's that's the war
going and and fighting that and you're
fighting it against your own self
against your own self sabotage
that's trying to stop you so that is to
me that's kind of the
the coming into who you were already
you already were that but you just
didn't know it
and through these actions you you
realize and you go wow i had no idea
i was gonna have a podcast i had no idea
i was gonna be talking to
587 people in writing finding ultra and
finding ultra part two you know
i had no or whatever else is out there
right but it's but
but but it's in the doing right the
waging of the war
is is is action based right
whereas i think a lot of people are are
maybe they're they're pursuing some
self-inquiry but
it's an intellectual exercise and
they're they're sort of awaiting the
epiphany
exactly and i think for me i can tell
you that i spent many years
in that in that world inside my head
wasting my time it's like therapy it's
like going there you know
you know and you know i think i've
written like 20 books now which is kind
of amazing to me since my
first book came out when i was 55 right
right
and it's absolutely true that before i
wrote
any one of those books i had no clue
that i was going to write that book
you know not like it wasn't like i was
sitting oh i've got this whole
uh magazine of books like bullets in a
in a mag
waiting to go i had no idea at all so
the but
the the the point of that is
that we find out who we are by the works
that we produce
but until until you actually start to
once you start to act like i'm sure it's
the same in ultra fitness or anything
like that
once you actually start then you then
you start to discover things
right the path unfolds in front of you
it does slowly
not you know easily yeah the idea being
that
what what paralyzes many is they want to
see
what that path looks like or at least
you know be able to forecast
pretty far down the line before they
take the first step and it just doesn't
work that way you have to take those
steps
not knowing and trust that that you know
the brick will get laid right you know
one step in front of you as you go
yeah and it is scary i mean it is the
unknown that we're going through
going into and it's scary there's no
doubt about it
right let's transition now to
another facet of mental well-being what
happens when
we lose complete control over
our ability to reason to
register our surroundings to even
recognize
our loved ones or comprehend the
distinction between
memory and reality i'm of course talking
about dementia
and more specifically alzheimer's
disease
no deep dive into mental health would be
complete without discussing
one of the most prevalent and
devastating mental health disorders
alzheimer's is a disease that currently
afflicts over 47 million people
worldwide right now
and that stat amazingly is predicted to
triple by 2050
but it's especially important to talk
about alzheimer's
in light of the work of my next guests
aisha and dean scherzai
are husband and wife neurology team
together they co-direct the alzheimer's
prevention program
at loma linda university where they
study all things brain health
with a very specific focus on lifestyle
interventions
that can prevent cognitive decline and
neurodegeneration
their work is proving that alzheimer's
is preventable and even reversible
in 90 of cases this clip
is absolutely mind-blowing and i hope
that it can serve as life-changing
information for you
if you or someone you love is affected
by this horrible disease
i mean we're talking about every other
disease in decline pretty much every
other disease or death
from every other disease in the client
yet mortality and death from alzheimer's
in just the last 10 years has grown more
than
80 percent part of that is because we're
aging society we're doing better with
the
yeah we have more diabetes we have more
obesity we have more
of all these other diseases but we're
surviving them with machines with
surgeries with these catheters all these
things we're living past
what we would have lived right we can
survive diseases we can survive
used to kill us exactly but when it
comes to
what's left behind is our brain at the
end of the day we're left with our brain
and that's the cumulative problems
over 50 60 years that actually end up in
being alzheimer's at the end or dementia
in general alzheimer's and that's where
we bring
um the new kind of conversation so when
you begin this journey
15 some odd years ago uh i would imagine
you know like you kind of alluded to
earlier your colleagues are like this is
career suicide what are you doing
you're gonna start looking at uh you
know lifestyle medicine for this
and so i think it would make sense to
kind of explain
or at least talk through some of the
myths and the misconceptions
about this disease particularly this
notion that
it's a purely genetic situation like if
you have the gene this is what's going
to happen and there's nothing
you can do about it right um that has
been the misunderstanding for such a
long time and
you know there are there are a few genes
in alzheimer's disease um maybe less
than five percent
of the genes that you know completely
determine
um whether somebody gets alzheimer's or
not as a matter of fact if you have
those genes you're definitely going to
get it
but even for those you can push it off
for a very long time for the rest of
them
for you know the 95 plus percent of the
genotypes
it's it's quite clear that what you do
in your life
the type of food that you eat whether
you exercise or not or the level of
stress that you have
determine whether you're going to get
the disease in your early 60s
or in your late 90s right right so the
magnitude
of how these genes are expressed is
contingent upon
what you're eating and how you're moving
and how you're living your life
completely
right completely if you take care of
your brain you've taken care of all the
body because
now this this thing that we're trying to
create living mind kind it's about the
mind
mindful living and uh so this
affects the totality of your body for a
brain it's something
more than that because you here you have
emotions as well you have motivation you
have all this so
one of the elements of our book is not
just saying
this is bad and this is good but where
we have failed people
is we just throw it at them without
giving them the tools of how to apply to
their life
so mindful living is is the unique thing
about our book
more than even the science and it's a
vicious cycle
if you feel good you know based on
the good neurochemicals being produced
appropriately if you take care of your
brain and if you have a healthy mind
that um owning that um mindfulness in
your life and applying it on a regular
basis
can help you take better care of
yourself so there you go
you have a healthy brain you have the
tools to take care of your heart
and the rest of your body right and
everything follows from that
depression recently papers came several
i mean
whenever as a science we don't say paper
came paper means nothing
it has to be multiple and validated lots
of papers say that one of the major
causes of depression
inflammation yeah so it keeps coming
back
yeah we keep slipping i call it logic
slip and a lot of times when you have
debates you keep building these logical
sequence and you
work past the the fallacies and
everything and then it slips again
that's what's happening in nutrition and
lifestyle and and
you make the case i mean the case for
diet has been made
over and over again and then all of a
sudden slip again now we know
inflammation and all these things
actually even affect
the depression anxiety everything and
all of these diseases right you
can't you can't extract one thing from
the other
right and it seems like uh the
the advent of functional medicine
lifestyle medicine
is is growing and people are starting to
embrace this
idea that it's not just one treatment
protocol that we have to kind of look at
a person in a holistic way
and you know treat them um
you know all the way down to you know
how they how they interact with their
family members and at work and what's
their relationship with their boss and
you know all of that stuff
is crucial right to kind of solving this
problem
we have to look at a person in a
holistic way
but can we also look at the totality of
our emotions
the joys as well as the sorrows in a
holistic way
is there anything we can learn from
negative emotions and
mental health struggles is there a way
to find healing through
reframing our perspective on depression
committing to total honesty about our
feelings
and exercising vulnerability well
kundalini yoga master and dear friend
guru singh
addresses all of those questions in the
following clip
i encourage you to spend some time with
this next one
and really absorb what he has to say
it's a simple perspective shift but
it is by no means easy to do please
enjoy
and take in the wisdom of guru singh
then i think the the pace the
accelerated pace
with which culture society
is advancing is changing is evolving
is is is so outpacing
our evolutionary um
ability to uh adapt
you know we're still we're
evolutionarily you know
built into our gna into our genetic code
is a life that that looks like
whatever's going on in the
you know the indigenous tribes of of
africa
and if you go to those places you know
you always hear these stories oh i went
to
i went to india i went to peru i went
wherever it is and
people who spend time with cultures that
are relatively immunized from
the way that we live realize how much
happier they are how much more connected
they are how much more
communal they are and and and and
content they have
all of these things that that we're
trying so desperately
to build into our own lives but which
continue to
elude us because the very things that
contribute
to that which we seek we've decided are
are either optional or not important
think about these depression has a value
because when you're depressed
you can go into some pretty deep places
some pretty dark places
and when you go into those places with
the sense of
let me explore rather than you know let
me feel horrible
those deep places can confine
character can find parts of your being
that are able to come forward there
would never be it
noticed if you were just giddy and happy
all the time
and the same thing with good grief right
grieving
sadness grief you know these are also
valuable
moments so depression
and grief and sadness
are all things that when they come upon
us
we should go into fully but giving
ourselves the space
i'm going to take a sick day because i'm
feeling really sad
and let me go into this sadness let me
process this sadness let me gain the
messaging from this sadness
just as if i was to take a sick day
because i've got the flu
these are things that need to be viewed
within the individual life
but the fact is is that diving into that
that depression diving into that sadness
and taking off the mask and admitting it
and saying you know i'm not looking for
anything
from you but i just gotta say you know
what's happening in the world today or
what's happening in my world today
or what just happened you know in my
home or what
whatever you know you know i'm not
feeling good
or you could even say if it's chronic
you know what i haven't felt good for 10
years
and then all of a sudden and then let's
go the cocktail party goes silent
yeah but you know to heck with the
cocktail party
you know let's be honest this is the
thing i mean i think it's terrifying for
people if i
admit that i'm not feeling good you know
what are people going to think of me
and i think that goes right back into
this discussion
around shame and around vulnerability
you know we're taught to
support ourself in a certain way to
navigate social circles
in a manner that will allow us to
maintain that
trajectory of upward mobility and
to act in contravention of that is to
put at risk
everything that you've staked your life
upon which provokes fear
and that sense of shame is the ultimate
uh
prophylactic against behaving in a way
that actually would contribute to
greater health if we're ashamed about
something
the most terrifying thing would be to
shed light on it to
expose that in a vulnerable way to
another human being
the stake can be very high for people
but ultimately
placing that into
into uh you know a social setting in
which it can be
discussed in a mature way
is the path to healing but it requires
us to be vulnerable
and we're not raised to be vulnerable
but
i think that vulnerability that
willingness to be vulnerable is the
ultimate courage
and when you can expose that which
you're ashamed of
from a place of wanting to heal it
asking for help allowing yourself to be
vulnerable requires a tremendous amount
of courage
[Music]
okay so far in this deep dive
we've covered so many aspects of mental
health but
i would really be remiss if we fail to
cover ptsd
a very serious affliction obviously that
impacts somewhere between 11 to 20
percent of all
iraq war veterans and 30 of vietnam vets
something like 22 veterans
take their own lives every single day
which is just horrifically insane
war of course takes its toll but
i think it's incumbent upon all of us to
to better address the undeniably
significant psychological effects that
we ask our brave men and women to endure
there is a path to healing and we're
going to discuss that path
our steward for that exploration is iraq
war combat veteran
sarah lee sarah is a former army
sergeant who served eight years in the
military
including a 14-month deployment to iraq
in 2004 for
operation iraqi freedom 2. her story
is heartbreaking upon returning home
from deployment
she basically endured one thing after
another until
she found herself 100 pounds overweight
and descending into
this very dark depression that became
so bleak that in april 2017
she very nearly took her own life
and the absolutely bone chilling part
about our conversation is the fact that
the very same day in fact at the exact
same time that sarah and i recorded this
conversation which was a fair while ago
just 13 miles away from us another young
military veteran
[Music]
in a fit of depression and despair
pulled out a 45 caliber semi-automatic
pistol with a laser sight
and opened fire on a crowd of mostly
20-somethings ultimately killing 12
people
before fatally shooting himself
and i think the confluence of these two
events
really underscores and emphasizes the
severe gravity
of our mental health epidemic sarah
thankfully found a way towards healing
which
as you'll hear in a moment all began
with a bicycle
[Music]
so what what was the lowest moment
it was the day right before i bought my
bicycle right before i bought the
bicycle
and uh i just i knew after the surgery
i'd be limited my
my neck had gotten bad my knees i
felt like i'd have to start all over i
had no muscle base anymore for because
that's when i'm not really in pain is
when i have the muscle in place
and i just felt like i just didn't even
i'm just not capable of of anything
anymore yeah was it depression
was there suicidal ideation was there
you know what was the mindset
there yes i i definitely was i guess i
i can say that i was fantasizing about
it
and uh that evening was probably the
the closest i'd ever come in my head to
to an attempt
i hadn't attempted suicide prior and uh
i just decided that that i can't
do that to my i've lucked out with very
loving family and
um i couldn't do that to my parents so
but even in that moment you didn't have
friends or family
around that had a sense that you were
going sideways
no no one really knew i was going
through any of this until i
i made a facebook post about it and
basically i said a lot of the things
that i've said here um
i expressed and explained that
since getting out of the military it
feels like i've kind of lived
a whole lifetime and there's really
nothing left to do
that's kind of where i'd arrived in my
mind i said that
i've had these nagging gnawing thoughts
that i'm
really only living life to fulfill some
sort of obligation
to the people that love me and
nothing more and i felt so guilty about
saying that
because everybody that cares for me is
probably like you know
i thought she has a great time with me i
could have done or said something
differently and
usually people end up thinking that
after it's too late that's why
i decided i need to get this post out
there and um
the reason i waited is because i the
bike trip was already in motion
i was like here's what i'm doing about
it because i didn't want to just come
out and say
all right so you okay gotcha so you post
you went public with it after you were
already kind of well into
the solution i made that post and then i
described
the the plan for the journey and
the support was unbelievable that it
wasn't like i expected it would be
like private messages you know you're in
my thoughts and
uh if there's anything i can do you know
stuff like that people were like
this is amazing i'm sharing this and
maybe other veterans will
kind of decide to do something yeah
about it or
just try to take back some of that
purpose for themselves try to take on a
challenge
well so when you're in that moment
you're in that darkest you know that
darkest moment
what was it that clicked inside of you
to
do something about it like take me from
that moment
to the moment of deciding that you're
gonna you know
get a bike and ride a bike and how this
whole ride came together
yes i i'd been planning the trip with a
friend a friend i met through a mutual
friend of marine and
we talked about but i hadn't purchased
my bicycle yet and i was still really
struggling on the fence about
you know actually going through with it
and i had an evening where
i just i just tend to stare at the wall
sometimes for a while and
think about big stuff or just anything
really and i get kind of lost in some of
that
and i think i just convinced myself that
i think people would be okay and that
basically it goes back to coming home
without my friend just
i don't know if i deserve to be here
and i'm not even taking advantage of the
life that
has been gifted to me because of someone
else's sacrifice and
it just really gnaws gnaws at me
it still does but um
i i had kind of a a game plan
for if i'd gone through with with taking
my life and everything and it was a bit
elaborate but
it was kind of like the least one of the
maybe the least shocking kind of
ways i just didn't want to
hurt anyone or scar anybody yeah you
know
so um that night
i was i was right there i'll say i was
like right there and
i ended up just falling asleep
and so the next day i was like that's it
that's i can't do one more night like
that
i'm not gonna get through it i'm not
gonna get through it so
i literally just woke up and went and
purchased my bicycle the next day
right to the bike store yes and you had
had so the plan was
the the plan was already in motion to do
a ride
prior to that you just hadn't taken any
action on it yet right i
purchasing the bicycle was like the
the decision like that decision maker
and had you
been a cyclist like had you
ridden a bike before no not well not
since
ninth grade other than just being a kids
around the neighborhood no
grade school was the last time i'd
ridden a bicycle
so but it comes right back it really
does
i took the bicycle the adage is true
when she learned how to ride it like
riding a bike and everyone
would say it and i'd be like and then i
got on it and i'm like okay that's why
that exists
it really does come right back so when
you think back on
this bike ride
is it the adventure aspect of it
is it the challenge aspect of doing
something that
was very difficult and maybe you thought
you couldn't do
was it the connecting with the veterans
and
just americans in general what aspect of
that do you think
has been the most impactful on your
healing process
or is it just all of those things
together well
the easy answer would be all of it and
the truest answer would be all of it but
uh
i really feel that
i i wasn't okay and
and i'm really no good to anyone unless
i'm good to go
and this the reconnecting like you said
with your body with nature
and with people it i think it just
really takes all
all three of those things that's why i
want to do this next step
and i've i felt
like my life was changed forever
in a really good way
from east to west
i just i like to relive some of the days
randomly
throughout my day and um i i just i want
to facilitate like smaller versions of
of what i for like you know experience
firsthand
this healing i want to help other
veterans get a sense of that or at least
introduce them to it
well well well here we are final clip
and i can think of no better way to
close out this deep dive than with the
story of hakim tafarai
hakeem is quite the extraordinary human
he's an ambassador of running culture
and mindfulness
he's a master of many a martial art from
kung fu to tai chi
he's also an herbalist a massage
therapist a vegan
a father and a practitioner of many a
spiritual path from buddhism
to taoism and essentially everything in
between
he speaks in this final clip about
the light at the end of darkness
and my desire is that if you're
listening to this because you're
struggling with anxiety
or depression or any other mental health
malady
that you find comfort that you find
healing
and that you find hope in hakeem's story
you need something
come to the temple at the time the time
i didn't know what the temple was
she said come to the temple i was like
okay
so i drive up there and i've got this
big
springfield 45 next to me
and at the time i just got off the phone
with my ex we had just gone into a major
argument
i'm i'm literally just like shaking
uncontrollably and i'm like do i just do
it right now
i'm looking at the gun i'm in front of
the temple
i'm looking at the gun
and then i'm like alright it i'm
gonna go do whatever this thing
is
i don't know what i'm gonna get into but
i'm gonna do it
that that could have been my last day on
the earth
and instead i chose to sit in front of a
wall
in silence for an hour and a half
when i was literally crawling on the
bottom like
i don't know if i can make it
that was kind of like the ladder that
was like yes you can
there's so much beauty in suffering
there's so much beauty and suffering and
i and i know it sounds so
it's not cliche but it's people are like
scratching their head how can you
suffer how can there be beauty and
suffering
when you go through the suffering that
a lot of us have that have been on the
show that have become successful
is because when you go through that
suffering you go through such a darkness
you go through
such a bottom feeder
kind of exposure that
you learn to have gratitude
for the smallest thing
the smallest thing and when i
when i think about um
the times when
i didn't think that i was gonna
really make it out of that space
there were times rich when
i would be in the car park of whole
foods
like crying crying my
heart out screaming at the top of my
lungs looking around
like how the did i end up in this
situation
because mental health and suicide is so
big
and and and and i know in this day and
age
it's being amplified and people are
talking about it but
[Music]
when you hit a certain level of
suffering and you think there is nothing
else
[Music]
you can look back at these times
in that darkness and be like man if i
didn't
know the depths and the levels of
darkness
i wouldn't be able to enjoy this moment
right now
[Music]
thus concludes today's deep dive into
mental health i really hope that you not
only enjoyed it but found it helpful
in closing if you are struggling please
please raise your hand and reach out for
help for a catalog of helpline resources
you can visit the website for the
national alliance on mental illness
at nami.org and if you're experiencing
suicidal ideation
i encourage you to call the suicide
prevention hotline at 1-800-273-talk
links to these resources can be found in
the description below
and in the show notes on the episode
page at ritual.com
if you found today's video valuable
please subscribe to my channel
and i'll see you in a few days with
another great episode
peace
[Music]
you